that's his look and that's where he's  been scoring this year Oh turn back the  clock there to bluff trevor booker  and desperate to get to the basket and  score and here you're gonna see the nice  reaction and you know back in the day  when he was a defender let's face it he  was 12 times all defense nine times on  the first team now you like the reaction  here because he gets double-teamed 29  years old on salmon look at Kobe keeping  the ball feeling it fire  this is like old times sow in throws to  tie the game and then the Lakers game of  saud Kobe came out furious for three how  is a dagger that's the old Hogan out of  his thirteen hundred and forty six games  so just under a third it's the free 35  Kobe's got the Lakers last check Brian  for three  [Applause]  well Kobe give them one last gamer  Bryant on the moves with the jumper 50  points and the Lakers lead he has been  great and on his final night it's one  last glimpse of greatness